[Music]
in the past year or so three internet
Mysteries popped up that really got my
attention they may seem very different
but trust me they're connected the first
one is about a girl who found a door in
the basement of her Airbnb she opened it
and inside there was an abandoned
shopping mall the second story is about
Javier who woke up in a hospital in the
year 2027 in an alternate universe in
his version of the future everyone on
Earth has vanished he's the only one
left and he has the video to prove it
the third mystery is known as the back
rooms a reality adjacent to ours that if
the conditions are just right you could
accidentally fall into then you find
yourself lost in an endless Maze of
dingy carpet fluorescent light and
yellow wallpaper and around every corner
foreign
[Music]
Mall a deserted World a maze in another
dimension what do these have in common
uh terrible places to have a vacation
um uh good places to hide a body what
are you doing hello you asked what those
places have in common I'm answering your
question I was being rhetorical I'm
trying to build drama and suspense oh
well well you're on over on channel
buddy boy
what these locations have in common is
liminality well more specifically
they're liminal spaces a liminal space
is defined as a place of transition a
threshold between two distinctly
different points signaling the end of
one and the beginning of another
limitable spaces do exist as physical
locations but they could also be an
emotional experience they occur during
periods of uncertainty and major life
changes events like a divorce or breakup
the death of a loved one the birth of a
child moving to a new city ending or
starting a new career all these create
liminality in our mind meaning our life
before this event is over and a new
period of life is about to begin
liminality is the unease and
apprehension we feel during this
transition liminal spaces in the real
world are a bit more difficult to Define
but you know one when you see one think
of an airport in the middle of the night
school during summer break a house just
after someone moves out or in this case
an accidentally discovered abandoned
shopping mall
[Music]
you could tell by the video that she's
having fun but she's also a little
uncomfortable she's experiencing the
anxiety of a liminal space that while
not all liminal spaces are so unsettling
the type of space currently coursing
through the internet will have a few
common features they'll feel both
familiar and strange if you browse
through photos on the liminal space
subreddit you'll come across many
locations that you could swear you've
been to evoking a strange feeling of
nostalgia for a place you've never been
another common trait is that places are
out of context like a waiting room with
one chair a plane with no seats a
flooded Metro station or a submerged
staircase have you ever watched a video
of the Titanic on the bottom of the
ocean when you see the staircases and
Furniture completely underwater this
evokes liminality this out of context
imagery triggers anxiety similar to
uncanny valley the feeling that
something is just not right liminal
spaces are often places you might have
visited as a child roller ranks are
commonly thought of as liminal
bowling alleys arcades or an empty Chuck
E cheese the only
Chuck E cheese is a crowded Chuck E
cheese
[Applause]
you got that right but something you'll
notice about all these places they're
empty and that seems to be the most
unsettling aspect of all these spaces
are transitional because they're in
between places not meant for anyone to
stay very long but they're still meant
for people yet these sit empty waiting
to fulfill their use waiting for people
people that in some cases never arrive
now all of us from time to time stumble
into a liminal space a supermarket in
the middle of the night an empty office
an amusement park off-season
but what if you woke up one day and the
entire world was deserted and every
space was a liminal space
[Music]
[Laughter]
Tick Tock has no shortage of quote
unquote time travel accounts some are
entertaining but they're mostly just
goofy but one account stands out from
the rest Javier a Spanish Creator whose
account is unigo sobre vivinte which
means
oh you speak Spanish now
well this account
[Music]
okay I get it do you mind if I no I
like well this account is unique because
he posts actual videos of deserted
department stores supermarkets even
entire football stadiums Javier woke up
in a hospital in Valencia on February 13
2027 and claims to be in an alternative
Universe apparently at some point in the
near future every human on earth just
disappears he said that when he woke up
he couldn't remember his name or where
he lived he went outside and everyone
was just gone everything appeared just
like 2021 but electronic devices showed
2027. now his videos are fascinating and
I'll link to his account down below and
when you're watching remember that
Valencia has a population of over 800
000 people and the surrounding area has
almost 2 million people
and despite Valencia being a big city
there are no people in these videos he
goes to random Apartments
he crashes at exclusive hotels
he accepts challenges to go to places
that most people can't go fire and
police departments
even steals a few police cars
he goes to a military base
some Skeptics claim he's recording all
this early in the morning he responds by
recording himself walking by public
signs with a Time on them
there aren't many tick-tockers who can
reprogram a public digital sign he's
challenged to go to a hospital not an
old deserted one an actual modern
hospital and he does it
a lot of the places he visits do have
off hours but hospitals are full of
people 24 7 but not these Javier also
claims our two worlds are connected he's
able to interact with objects in his
world which affects objects here for
example a Spanish television show
challenged Javier by leaving a book
hidden on their set and told him to find
it and move it he did
this is
and when the studio went back to watch
the security footage you can see the
door open and close and just for a quick
moment you see some kind of figure flash
by
um
[Music]
that would be terrifying to wake up
alone in the world where every place you
visit is a different liminal space but
worse than that would be waking up in a
single liminal space that goes on
forever and that place has a name in the
back rooms
[Music]
foreign
is an internet mystery that began like
many internet Mysteries do on 4chan
someone asked members to submit
disquieting images that just feel off an
anonymous user posted this Photograph
everyone who saw the image agreed it was
strangely familiar but unsettling though
nobody could explain why finally a
follow-up comment described it if you're
not careful and you know clip out of
reality in the wrong areas you'll end up
in the back
or it's nothing but the stink of old
moist carpet the madness mono yellow the
endless background noise of fluorescent
lights and maximum humbas and
approximately 600 million square miles
of randomly segmented empty rooms to be
trapped in God save you if you hear
something wandering around nearby
because it sure as hell has heard you uh
no clip well no clip is a video game
term when two objects overlap that's
clipping no clipping means crossing
boundaries in a game that you're not
supposed to cross and ending up an area
is not meant for the player the back
room's Theory says it's possible to no
clip into a different reality adjacent
to ours a reality you're not meant to
ever see remember Limitless spaces are
transitional you're not supposed to stay
there very long you instinctively want
to get out to move on the back rooms are
unnerving because you can't it's an
endless liminal space with no Escape
something about the back rooms connected
with people and an entire culture was
organically developed around the concept
completely Community Driven the back
rooms has become crowdsourced IP with
its own Cannon and lore there are now
hundreds of levels of back rooms each
with their own stories their own rules
inhabitants objects even hazards fans
can contribute to the lore through a few
different wikis completely dedicated to
the back rooms still the back rooms
lived in dark corners of the internet
what brought the concept to the
mainstream was a series of short videos
by a Creator named Kane Parsons using an
ingenious combination of live action and
3D animation wrapped in a low-tech
package these videos give us a glimpse
of what being trapped in the back rooms
would feel like the videos also prove
that liminal spaces are not a fringe
Theory millions of people have watched
these clearly the concept of liminality
is universal the video series begins
with a group of kids shooting what looks
like a student film in 1996 the camera
operator suddenly no clips through the
ground and and falls into the back rooms
yeah yeah
hello
it doesn't take long for us to realize
that we're not alone in the back rooms
there's some entity aware of us and
seems to follow us through the Maze of
empty yellow office space hello
some moments are definitely scary but
even when not being outright terrifying
the entire series is unsettling As You
Through The Eyes Of The Lost cameraman
explore the back rooms you have a sense
that you've been here before I certainly
have there are certain angles and ways
the walls are arranged that remind me of
offices that I've worked at at different
points in my life I work jobs where the
only light was overhead bulbs and the
only time you'd see the Sun or the sky
was if you were lucky enough to run out
for lunch that was my job last year
actually for anyone who's worked in an
office like this there's a feeling of
claustrophobia of being trapped like a
prisoner where time seems to slow down
and hours feel like they last for days
unfortunately for people trapped in the
back rooms time doesn't exist at all
there is no past and no future so no
brief respite for lunch no exhilaration
at the end of a long boring day the only
time is the present and like the space
itself the present is infinite
eventually our hero discovers graffiti
on a wall which tells him to stay still
that turns out to be a terrible idea
after fleeing from The Entity were taken
to various locations which are
essentially Recreations of common photos
of liminal spaces The Empty Apartment
the deserted quad and Kane's short film
then Builds on tried and true horror
movie tropes like Pursuit claustrophobia
disorientation and of course the jump
scare
oh
foreign
subsequent videos build on the lore of
the back rooms the tone shifts from jump
scare horror into more of a dystopian
sci-fi thriller it seems that there are
ruptures in our world that allow people
to accidentally pass into the back rooms
this explains why the number of missing
people is on the rise eventually a
corporation creates a prototype machine
to access the back rooms and this is
hailed as a world saving technology
because the back rooms are so large
hundreds of millions of square miles
they can be used for storage housing
even transport now of course things go
wrong along the way we have researchers
trying to map the back rooms getting
lost and falling into different levels
and all kinds of Chaos
oh my God everything okay
um across
Curry
okay
the series is still ongoing so subscribe
to Kane pixels if you want to see what
happens next but you don't have to wait
for Kane other creators have picked up
the mantle and attempted to continue the
story
anything who just saw someone running
Juanita Estevez now age 16 last team
Yuba City California November 27 1984
call 800.
hello can you help me get down there's
something up here please
baked right where you are we're gonna
try and get you down to me all these
versions are equally interesting and
unsettling the back room's concept has
spawned other media as well a viral Tick
Tock shows someone using Google Earth to
zoom in on a location in Japan as they
move inside the building we see the
familiar wallpaper carpet fluorescent
lights and this time different objects
and entities Indie developers are
publishing video games based on the back
rooms and liminal spaces animalopolis is
one that looks interesting it combines
The Uncanny liminal space concept with
classic first person horror and puzzle
solving elements liminality may seem
like the cool new thing and it's no
coincidence that its popularity surged
during coveted lockdowns when everyone
was feeling isolated but the concept has
been around a long time the phrase was
created by Arnold van gennep in his book
Rites of Passage released in 1908 and
getup was more focused on life
experiences like transitioning from
childhood to adulthood graduating high
school or moving to a new city this
concept of an in-between place whether
physical or emotional has been explored
in media and pop culture for years Rod
Serling famously said it is the middle
ground between light and Shadow between
science and Superstition and it lies
between the pit of Man's fears and the
summit of his knowledge The Shining is
an entire movie based around the idea of
liminality the abandoned Hotel spooky
hallways that go on forever and you
never know what lurks around Each corner
thank you
[Music]
horror movies like it follows and Silent
Hill also used liminal spaces to amp up
the creepiness and recently the Apple TV
sci-fi thriller Severance uses liminal
spaces as a backdrop for the entire
series the large empty spaces hallways
that create such a confusing maze that
you have to draw maps to find your way
around and the Dual reality concept of
severance is similar to The Back rooms
you have one reality where you live your
life as you normally would but when you
get to work you are severed from this
reality and transition to a new reality
a reality comprised completely of
liminality and you can't have a
post-apocalyptic story without
liminality that feeling of being the
last person on Earth walking through
spaces once teeming with life now left
abandoned and forgotten the human brain
is not wired for this kind of isolation
which is why these tropes are so
effective and speaking of the Apocalypse
let's Circle back to our two other
Mysteries and see if we can figure out
what's really going on
Javier the lonely Survivor in Spain
he has a very interesting and compelling
Tick Tock account and people are
constantly trying to debunk him some say
his hands look different in each video
implying that he's actually a team and
there may be something to that you have
to dig really deep but it turns out that
Javier is working with the city of
Valencia on a media project called The
Lonely Survivor which is why he has
access to all these places and why he's
able to clear out entire stadiums busy
streets even sections of hospitals so
it's not some future reality it's just a
TV production team with filming permits
now Javier won't admit his account as
just a project and I don't blame him
it's fun to maintain an air of mystery
but if you watch enough of his videos
you realize it would be so easy for him
to prove that he's in a different
reality or in the future he could show
the dates on tombstones he could time
lapse an entire weekend at a typically
busy airport or just fly his drone
around the city at rush hour he never
does this his environments are highly
controlled but still the videos are fun
and the young lady who discovered an
abandoned Mall in the basement of her
Airbnb the video has a supernatural feel
to it but it's really not that strange
her Airbnb is actually a hotel that
shares a building with the Ocean Walk
Mall in Hollywood Beach Florida an Ocean
Walk is what's called a dead Mall though
a better name for a dead mall is
probably a zombie mall it's a shopping
mall that nobody really goes to anymore
but it's still open and somewhat
functioning and dead malls are
everywhere all over the country and it's
not hard to understand why malls are
dying Amazon well pretty much online
shopping and the online economy but when
I was a kid you bought your groceries at
the supermarket and you bought
everything else at the mall clothes
Electronics Sporting Goods toys
everything and in many Suburban towns
like the ones I grew up in the mall was
a community social Center families would
spend all day there you'd shop eat shop
and eat some more all day and as a
teenager we'd hang out at the mall we'd
go around lunchtime we'd see a movie
lurk in the arcade and talk to girls you
you I wanted to but I wasn't very good
at it
well high school and college kids from
the area often work at these shops in
fact this is the mall that we went to
when I was a kid and worked at all
through high school and college back in
those days the mall was always packed
when was that the 1950s
not that long ago but close enough but
now look at it that's not the mall I
remember there is a sadness to these
spaces there's Nostalgia there's the
reminder that everything moves forward
Everything Changes what once was will
never again be these Transitions and
Rites of Passage are an important part
of life they show our courage our
resilience our perseverance they make us
who we are but whether a location in the
world or a transitional moment in our
lives every liminal space has the same
point
to find your way out
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today my name is AJ that's Heckle fish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor and
like subscribe comment and share that
stuff really helps out the channel and
if you have a story you'd like covered
or information you want to share you can
email tips at the yfiles.com and
obviously I can't do every story but
almost every topic we cover here comes
from you so email anything you like
anytime I read all of it and special
thanks to our patrons for making this
channel possible we couldn't do it
without your support and if you'd like
to support the Y files there's a link
below until next time be safe be kind
and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
thank you